hey y'all I know it's Friday but getting
your Sunday best because today certified
country is headed to Mother Church aka
Nashville's Ryman Auditorium for this
year's ACM honors the show airs tonight
September 15th on CBS but it actually
filmed last month and you know your girl
was on the scene so ACM honors is all
about celebrating the country music
community from the superstars behind the
scenes to the ones we all know and love
like Reba dolly George and so so many
more today I'm gonna take you inside
Kelsea Ballerini x' rehearsal and over
to the red carpet where let me tell you
couple's gold they write an all-time
high
[Music]
Dunham's twins yeah it's a driving it
okay so the gene weed milestone oh yeah
I want to read you a few names birth
Brooks Luke Bryan Kenny Chesney Merle
Haggard Loretta Lynn Taylor Swift Carrie
Underwood Blake Shelton the list goes on
how does it feel to be in that company I
don't know it's crazy it makes me really
want to say something like eloquent
tomorrow when I get it but I just get so
nervous I mean it's an honor but I just
want to do a good job do you write a
speech ahead of time or now I'll
probably think think of it I won't write
it down but I'll think of what I need to
say before
I get to do legends kind of how we wrote
it with Hilary Lindsey which is like
she's the reason that I started writing
song so like this thing with her on the
stage of the Ryman is incredible and
then I get to do a medley of my three
number ones so it's it's a big thing I'm
very excited there's gonna be a lot of
legends in the audience pun intended
we've got dolly Reba I was just gonna
say I saw Dolly's singing on the front
row and so help me Lord if she is
singing there for my performance because
I can't look at her I can't look at her
[Music]
okay well the new album is coming sum it
up for me in about three words loss life
love love it you practice that it's an
order of loss into life and the love and
your love Morgan is he's embarking on
his like us like starting it off have
you given him any words of wisdom as he
kind of goes out on that he was he came
to see me on the road with lady a before
he started his ready out for a couple
weeks ago and he's like all right like
any last words and I went into the
cupboard and I got like the bottle of
vitamin C out and I got like all like
the emergency packets and a bunch of
Larabars
and just put it in a little envelope for
him and I was like that's my nice like
stay healthy go have fun babe but he's
killing it so proud of him yeah now real
talk are you sick of talking about your
wedding yet no I'm so excited
I mean I'm putting on an album and
getting married within a month so it's
like a big deal you know like to be able
to do both of those life milestones I
want to know what you're doing for the
bachelorette party because Nashville's
kind of the place to do I'm I'm going to
another place but it's soon and I have
excited that's what you get for waking
up in Vegas while her boo was out on the
road Kelsie was looking red-hot on that
red carpet but it was a date night for
some more of country's biggest couples
[Music]
how stunning is that thank you you want
to get the man of the hour in here tell
me about getting this ring from Aaron I
kind of know what she likes the stone is
from New York City it's like an uncut
diamond and then the rest of its custom
for her because I didn't I don't know I
couldn't like just buy something and how
did you react when you oh I saw I mean
it was so emotional and so perfect how
is wedding planning going are you
thinking about that part of it yet here
and there yeah we are um I think we're
kind of honing in on like the spring
time before we like kick off our tours
again and but yeah we're we're going
very slow at a glacial pace I think
we're just enjoying being engaged
announced today who's your farmer and
the new album thank you very much yes so
we got a new album called everybody
he's coming out it on September 22nd
available for pre-order now but we did
get a grad track today called who's your
farmer it's kind of a my redneck spiel
but the bottom line is I'm always saying
something you know quirky to her around
the house and I just thought who's your
farmer I would say that kind of flirty
and we wrote the song so it was inspired
on the back of a John Deere tractor
absolutely he turns me on so whatever he
sings I'm good with fix a drink buying
boats whatever hose boomy busiest man in
Nashville right now I gotta say I feel
like it I really do no rest for you you
look great though you don't look tired
and I think with an infidel that's a big
compliment I appreciate that it's pretty
intense because I kind of feel like when
one of them goes to sleep the other
wakes up house more and I saw her today
she looks like a rock star yeah I mean
she's doing amazing besides being you
know a little bit sleep-deprived like we
both are
we're just you know we're excited to
kind of start to learn how to be better
better and better parents every day and
you know get the kiddos out on the road
and try to do like this guy does yeah
they're good good yeah they're good
advice for him
oh no he's given me a ton don't let him
boys Lauren and the kiddos did step out
earlier that day to attend a private
listening party for TRS new album like
changes but she opted to stay home on
mommy duty that night on stage though
Thomas performed in the hit that he
wrote for her died a happy man however
we have got to talk about this earlier
performance you guys there was a
powerhouse medley of Reba hits in honor
of her big award
[Music]
what does this mean to you because you I
mean gotten tons of awards over the
years so why is this one special because
it is the Maybourne accident award and
Maybourne accident was a great friend of
mine we had wonderful fun times together
emotional fun times together and she did
so much for country music for Nashville
for the up-and-coming entertainers if it
wasn't for me for an action I don't know
where Blake Shelton would be today me
too now adding to the girl-power vibes
Dolly Parton was also honored for her
humanitarian efforts and in true Dali
fashion I got to tell you she made an
entrance she took her seat right in the
front row just before her award was
announced got the whole crowd buzzing
and she left right after she looked
amazing though of course the whole time
and she delivered a scene-stealing
acceptance speech program would grow
into something so large although I'm
certainly used to people saying that
about me you are gonna want to tune in
to see Miss Dolly in all her glory along
with so many other highlights there was
Chris Janssen channeling Johnny Cash
Chris Stapleton being well Chris
Stapleton Maren Morris honoring Glen
Campbell and King George Strait shut the
place down with a classic it was so so
good you guys the 11th annual ACM honors
airs on September 15th from 9:00 to
11:00 p.m. Eastern and Pacific on CBS
and if your country loving heart needs
more go ahead and subscribe to ET to see
all of our episodes of certified country
you can keep up with my adventures over
on Instagram I am at Sophia Lacy and
until next Friday have a great weekend
y'all